dumb hotel story about Kimbo Slice Kimbo
Slice time ultimate fighter yeah when
your guys were doing that they'd even
show this on the air so this guy I'm
Mikey mentions name on the show he lost
and you can drink all that alcohol you
want in the house and there's only at
the time there's only four of us left
still fighting Roy Marcus Jones
Mitrione myself that's the for fighting
right so one of you guys one of the
other guys is hammered hammered wasted
all of a sudden this guy gets super
racist in the house and there's a bunch
of black guys in the house starts
throwing up racial slurs and throwing up
these you know the hit hey Hitler stuff
I'll Hitler's write his name on this
piece of paper for me alright so he
starts doing all this stuff I'm sleeping
I have the biggest fight of my life the
next day and I thought it was a dream
Kimbo Slice and Marcus Jones and this
and this D'Amico and thus D'Amico Rogers
comes in my room they go yo chop get up
dog get up man I'm like oh hazard three
large black guys around my bed Kim goes
yo man this dude's down to talk about
our people we're about to Jack him up I
live a thousand Jimmy oh excuse me
talking about our people dawg let's go F
this dude up Mike listen uh you guys
realize I said I'm not down with the
race thing but you realize I'm not black
right Kim wheels you ain't black
nobody goes damn that's crazy
turn around leaving out here that's what
like job you can't tell what the hell he
is a night I go hey Kimbo that's racist
I'll use wild just cuz I'm athletic can
fire y'all be black y-you could be wow
that's interesting man yeah why